- [Interviewer] Alright, Rebecca.
- Hello.
- [Interviewer] Rebecca,
Where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Rebekkah] Long Beach.
- [Interviewer] Long Beach.
And you grew up with
both parents, one parent?
- [Rebekkah] Both parents
until about third grade
and they divorced.
- [Interviewer] Are you living with mum?
- [Rebekkah] Both, and then
eventually just my dad.
- [Interviewer] Oh is that right?
That's unusual,
how did you end up with
your dad for so long?
- My sister was also going
through the separation boat,
back and forth thing.
And she kind of chose to go with my mom,
And I kind of chose to go with my dad.
I don't know.
I think it was more like our
personality types at the time.
- [Interviewer] What did,
how did you end up in the-
working at the strip clubs?
How did that come about?
- Do you want to hear the full story?
- [Interviewer] I'd love
to hear the full story.
- I was dating this guy for,
at this point about a year.
And I started dating him
when I was in high school.
And when I got out, I started waitressing
at this Mexican restaurant
and my car got totaled.
But my dad had bought the car
and me being young and naive,
I didn't realize that
because it wasn't my fault,
my dad got the insurance money
but he didn't give it to
me to get another car.
And my boyfriend wanted me to move.
So I needed to get another car quickly.
And so I went on Craigslist,
and I saw an ad for a bikini
waitress at an lax restaurant.
And I was like, Hmm.
And stupidly didn't look up
the address or see what it was.
And when I went, it was an
interview for, to be a stripper.
I thought it was to be a waitress.
And then he kept like pushing
the stripping envelope.
And I was like, huh.
So I actually said no.
And I was trying to find another job.
And then two weeks later, I
still haven't found anything
and I needed the money.
And I was like, okay, I'll
just start waitressing.
And they were like, okay,
you can start waitressing
but not at the location
that we interviewed you at
which is a really nice location near lax.
They move me to there one in the Valley.
And it was like,
for someone who had never
even been in a strip club,
to walk in there and then see
everything that was going on,
it was just like a lot.
So I started waitressing there,
and then I had a dancing
background previously to that.
And I'm watching these girls
and they were just like, not into it.
They're like, I dunno.
They weren't dancing, really.
And so I was talking
to my manager about it,
and he goes, well stop talking (beep),
and go up there and do it yourself.
And he gave you a hundred dollars
which, at the time for
me was a lot of money.
And I was like, okay.
And I made a thousand dollars.
And my first day to that-
cause there were people that had seen me
waitressing for awhile and
they wanted me to do it.
- [Interviewer] So you finally did it?
- So I finally did it and
they freak out and I was like
Oh my God, why would I
ever not want to do this?
So I quit waitressing that night
and I started dancing and
seven years later, here we are.
- [Interviewer] Wow. And what
are the upsides and downsides
of strippers for life?
- Upsides, I think are
very obvious, money.
- [Interviewer] You
don't pay taxes either.
Certain people do, certain
clubs don't send forms.
They don't even document you.
The downsides,
if you don't have boundaries,
people are going to push them a lot.
And it could put you
in a very emotionally
uncomfortable position.
But I felt that I didn't
have that issue really.
Cause it, I don't know.
Let me try to think about other negatives.
- [Interviewer] I mean, your personality
seems pretty strong.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So you can
say that to a guy who might be
pushing what he can get away with.
- Yeah.
- But it's, especially
if you don't know what's going on.
There are some things that I thought
that I knew what was going on
and then people would
throw something at you.
And you're just like, Whoa.
Like I didn't even know that was a thing.
Like, screwing you over
in a way that you could
never even imagine.
Even the the money that gets taken
from you and the people
that you're around,
it's a very different lifestyle.
And then the stigma that comes with it,
I had to hide it from my
family for a long time.
And obviously they, they kind
of caught on after a while.
The way that people treat you,
even going to the bank
and turning in your
ones is such a big deal.
Oh my goodness.
Don't get me started.
But I think it depends on the person.
If you come into it with a bad victim
for lack of a better word mentality
it's gonna chew you up and spit you out.
But I was able to kind of grab onto it,
and make it into something great.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, you seem to be very,
you have a great grasp
of what you're doing
and how you could handle it.
You don't seem to be on drugs,
you don't seem to be a drinker
but I'm sure there's lots
of ads you've seen, right?
- [Rebekkah] Oh yeah, Oh yeah.
So, when a stripper started
asking me if I had coke
and I said, "the soda?"
and this person said, wrong person to ask.
I've seen people smoke
meth next to me in Vegas.
There's a lot going on.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, last time?
- [Rebekkah] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And, so you
traveled around the country?
- So for a while I had a trailer and,
I drove from California
all the way to Florida
all the way down,
went up to,
Pennsylvania, Indiana,
went across all the way
back over to California.
- [Interviewer] Just going
from strip club to strip club?
- [Rebekkah] Strip club to strip club.
And sometimes not even calling in advance,
just kind of like showing
up. And hoping for the best.
- [Interviewer] Are you
like a featured, like-
- [Rebekkah] There's one,
only one club in Ohio
made me be a feature,
because it was a small town
and they didn't want to like,
it's a lot of competition, you know?
So they, they were like,
we'll call you a feature,
cause you're only going to
be here for the weekend.
- [Interviewer] I mean, I don't even know,
what is a feature?
- [Rebekkah] A feature would be someone
that's paid to be there.
And they're like, almost like an act like,
it's not traditional stripping.
- [Interviewer] It may concern
you if girls are getting,
Oh, she's gonna be in our
club next Saturday night.
- Exactly. But I just showed
up and they were like,
well, we don't want to
hire you as a dancer
because we're not sure you're
gonna be here for so long.
- [Interviewer] And the
advantage of traveling to do this
rather than staying at one club-
- I think that's a personal decision.
I- it's like, I like the newness of it.
And like, you learn so much about the,
"the local culture", when you're there.
- [Interviewer] Yes, What
states are interesting to you?
- I loved Ohio, I know
I just spoke about it,
like, the whole process of getting hired
and everybody was so nice.
And so over the top.
A guy paid me and another
dancer to do an hour by ourself.
He was not in the room.
He paid a thousand dollars for me and her
to just be in a room.
Like what, that was so kind.
Miami has its own issues,
but it was a lot of fun.
It's one of the biggest strip clubs.
And they have hours that
start at $5,000 for an hour.
Vegas, I worked at the
world's largest strip club.
There's so many cool things. And Tampa.
There was a place where you
had to pay your own money
to put your songs on the jukebox,
to play for when you go on stage,
and the place is like a shoe box.
But there's so many cool things.
- [Interviewer] And what
was, what's the most money
you've made in a night?
- Ooh, that was in Miami at 11.
It was a man who worked for Kellogg.
We did one of those $5,000 hours
but the club takes a huge cut of that.
And then we did another hour before that,
I was literally only
there for maybe five hours
and I made 4,500, but that's like-
- [Interviewer] Just advance naked form.
- I, we literally,
they brought masseuses up.
We were watching porn.
We ordered chocolate cake and French fries
and I showed him how to do handstands.
Like I literally didn't
even dance for him.
- [Interviewer] You were just hanging out?
- I was wearing my clothes the full-time.
It was awesome!
- [Interviewer] Yeah. See,
I've heard that a lot from-
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You know,
escorts and things like that.
Sometimes he's got prostitutes.
They just want, guys to-
you guys just want to hang out with them.
Yeah, especially in Vegas,
there were like five
or six different instances
where they literally
were just like, want arm candy.
So we'd go to like, all these
shows, we'd go to dinner with-
They wanted to be seen with you.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
It's actually nice to hear
because you kind of think it's all about
just like the physical act of sex.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] But sometimes it's not,
these guys just want companionship.
- Yep. I even went to
Hawaii one time with a guy
we had separate rooms,
didn't even hold hands.
It was crazy.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And so what
does your family think of
when they finally find out?
- I told them because-
- [Interviewer] Because
there is a stigma to it.
- Well yeah. But my dad shoots
like boudoir photography
and I had done makeup for him for awhile.
- [Interviewer] Well there you go.
- Yeah. So when I told them, I told them,
I don't want to talk about this,
but this is what's happening.
They knew the club that I worked at.
Cause they have a huge, special
that everybody knows about in the area.
And I was like, please just
don't go there anymore,
I have a job.
That was four years ago, and we have not
talked about it since.
- [Interviewer] What are
your plans for the future?
Where would you like to go from here?
- Sounds lame, but like my
end goal end goal is like,
I want to get a piece of land somewhere
and I want to be able to like homestead.
Like I really want to be
able to like grow my own food
and do all my own (beep)
and like sew my own clothes and whatever.
But immediate, more immediate plans,
I'm planning on going into porn.
- [Interviewer] Oh.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] That can make
you more money than stripping,
you think?
- Yes. Stripping is not, I don't know
if you know that the girls pay to strip.
- [Interviewer] They pay?
- So Vegas, for example, you
paid to get your Sheriff's card
like $75, pay to get your
alcohol and business license,
that could be two to $300.
Then, then every single night,
when you walk in the club,
you hand them a hundred dollars,
before you even start your shift.
- [Interviewer] Are you kidding?
- I'm dead serious.
So sometimes I leave
having paid all that money
and I didn't make any money.
So I owed money.
And that sucks when you're on stage,
people are staring at you.
You're not getting payed for
everything that you're doing.
You're getting all bruised and everything.
It's awful.
So not having that for sure money
sometimes really sucks.
- [Interviewer] Wow, I had no idea.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And, does it affect your
personal relationships?
Like romantic relations?
- I mean, yes and no, but I
have the wherewithal to know
that those people are not worth my time.
And I've kind of found my
friend group within it.
I had, the boyfriend, at
the time when I started,
when he found out he broke up with me.
And at the time it was devastating,
but I was just like, (beep) that guy.
Like, he's so lame,
but I've lost only like
one friendship over it,
but she was like really super religious.
So I kind of expected it of her.
Yeah. But really honestly,
it hasn't really changed much of my life.
- [Interviewer] Excellent.
Well Rebekkah, thank you
so much for talking to me.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] And good
luck with everything.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] For the future.